here we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another episode of your
favorite podcast you know the name
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's up y'all we back again
telling you about my week i got some
stuff i want to talk about
plus real world advice from a grown ass
man i got some good questions this week
so
i'm glad you're here i'm glad you're
still listening glad you're still
watching
so let's see what we can do uh this week
and i want to make it a regular thing uh
somebody finally sent a video in so
along with the text questions
i got a video but i just want to thank
everybody for listening to
[Applause]
rhymes
yeah rep and what grip wow
all right we're back y'all we back at it
again
um i had a uh i had a nice week
you know nothing too nothing too crazy
um i had a um i had this uh drive-in
theater show put on by the irvine improv
down at this
irvine spectrum and you know they did
like this sort of drive-in comedy show
on the roof of the parking lot with this
big screen projecting
you know just like a drive-in you know
projecting and everybody's listening to
the show on their
fam radio frequency and you know you
could hear the laughter the windows were
down and
you know it was you could sort of it
wasn't the same you know
nothing could duplicate being in a club
foot of a crowded club where
people are on top of each other and
everybody's laughing and it's such a
communal experience it's hard to
duplicate that
but that's what we're trying to do so i
do commend them for at least trying to
like
make the comics feel like they're still
comics and then
the people that are in the comedy
business make themselves feel like yeah
we're still in the comedy business but
you know we're still
putting on shows excuse me but
it was weird and i was rusty as hell man
i didn't realize how rusty i was i mean
if you think about it it's been like
five
six months since i've actually done
comedy at a high level where
i was in the pocket i knew what i was
talking about it was pow pow pow pow pow
this i felt myself like damn what are my
jokes and what am i talking about and
how do i talk about it i mean doing
comedy is not like riding a bike i mean
you got you have to you forget
you have to stay with it you have to
like stay committed and work on it every
single day
something it's not just writing it's
just about that the the act of
performing and so things are different
now so it's just
trying to figure out you know
who i am i mean i've done a couple of
shows i did this one rooftop show a
couple weeks ago and that one was fine
too and i did that one show
in the valley but it was like my first
time back so it was such a weird
environment
but this one was one that felt more like
this was a show that we're doing like
we're putting on a show like some sort
of regular thing that they're gonna do
and i just felt ill prepared i just felt
like damn who like
what who am i so you know it was weird
so we'll see you know it's it's like
the thing that gets me about it and i
was talking to jesus trail about this
because he was on
the show too you know and i said to him
i was like you know it's cool to do the
show but it almost
is detrimental to your to your your
attitude
to your well-being because like this
ain't normal like
you know we're just teasing ourselves
you know so here's a show with a bunch
of people and we feel like oh man but
it's just a tease are we going to do
this
normally like is the world going to get
back to normal or
what like what is the new normal gonna
be and so
when i experience a show like that and
i'm sitting there and feeling those good
feelings and vibes i start to think well
damn what
is this really and is will it ever be
the same
i'd like to think that it will but it
just was
it was weird so weird
relationship update you know let things
are going well with my girlfriend rachel
you know she did something the other day
that i just wanted to talk about on my
podcast that was like
it was real cool and it was so it's hard
to explain
but like early on in our relationship
like she gets really jealous
of things and maybe and insecure about
i think we all do this like you know if
somebody is upset about something
and they might say something and the
person thinks it's all about them so
they think like oh
you know and you're in your head about
like are you saying that because you
don't think i'm good enough or you don't
think
or you think it's my fault or did i do
something wrong and that's what happens
in the beginning of relationship you
know because you don't know each other's
language you don't know each other you
don't know why
we when we get upset you don't know what
the reasons
why the other person gets upset so you
oftentimes just blame yourself
right so we were kind of like that
especially her she's very much like that
but she's so different now that she just
gets me you know so now like i was
i i i'm a emotional guy i fly off the
handle about the dumbest things you know
like if i'm looking for something and
i'm like i'll be like
damn it where's that cord you know so
now rachel steps in and she says like
hey
do you have to be that upset about the
chord you know it's not that serious you
know
i don't think i don't think you know
maybe take it down a notch maybe it's
like oh i can't find the chord does it
have to be
so demonstrative and you know
i looked at her and i was thinking to
myself wow this is her really caring
about
me this is her being like okay i see
that you're getting upset
you don't need to be that upset it's not
that serious
uh maybe only let yourself get this
angry like three times a week
she said to me you only get three times
to be this angry and make sure they're
important
you know and it just really touched me
you know because i was like oh you you
really get me
you know you really understand what
makes me tick and what
what and that i need that i need someone
to be like
she's making me better is what i'm
saying you know she really like took
that time
and not made it about her like she just
it just it wasn't about
how she felt about my being angry or how
it bothered her and
obviously it does like when you're a
demonstrative person and then the other
person's like whoa this is a little bit
much
but she took the approach of being like
hey this is a little bit much
for me too like she did it for me
like you don't need to be this angry
about something so silly and it just
really like i
i took a pause you know because i'm
always in my head about these kinds of
things and i love
seeing these little the the growth and
the
you know how the relationship evolves
and that's what really that's what
that's what it really is about
is when you evolve to a point where
you know you don't
have these personal feelings
about what's happening you can literally
see
the other person's perspective and be
like oh they're
going through this i've seen this before
i know what's happening with them
maybe i can help alleviate some of the
stress
and anguish that they're feeling and
they'll be better and then in turn
our interaction will be better it's just
all that kind of thought process
just made me like really you know happy
uh i i found myself i was getting all
teary-eyed because you know and it's
like because i'm in my head you look at
me i'm still
i'm in my head about it because i i've i
see the calculation i see
i can see the growth i can see the
pieces moving you know that's just how
my brain works it's like that's how when
you're a comic
how you put together material because
you have to see like okay this can make
people feel this
they feel this way you're moving the
emotions that way to to make them feel
this
so i just see things like that so when i
see some like real growth and
improvement
in myself and in my relationship i just
go man that's great so
you know good relationship update
some other nonsense happen uh you know i
got
i tried to i bought this new mixer for
my
podcast i mean i'm using a for you nerds
out there you tech nerds this tech nerd
moment it's like so i got a h6 zoom
that i use but i use it for a usb
interface that just means that
i plug it into usb and now the computer
itself can see the different tracks you
can see
track one track two so it's a six track
mixer so
when you use audio interface that means
you can use like software on your
computer
to like record from that onto your
computer and you can have different
tracks so let's say i want to have like
my voice on one track i can have music
on another track right
but the h6 is limited so when i plug it
in usb interface and i plug
things into it sometimes some devices
there's a buzz
you know like my monitor so like for my
pocket for the
gaming which is error griffin gaming on
twitch i do it daily
i have the out the head i have the
headphones from the from the monitor
hooked up to the h6 zoom so i can hear
that
i can hear when i'm playing even though
the out to twitter twitch
it's a different line but anyways
there's a buzz
a hum coming from the monitor when i
have it plugged into this thing so i
said let me get a new
mixer let me get just a new one so it's
like on my desk it's got like
eight tracks right so
when it comes it has a weird usb
hook connection so it's like male to
male
so you need two sided male to male usb
cord
so i go buy one from best buy because i
live i live near a best buy
and it doesn't work so i get on with the
uh
the company's website and they have this
thing it says
24-hour technical support
so i get into the chat you know i go hey
um i'm having a problem setting up
you know the usb interface this fool was
like
okay um well that's uh beyond what we
talk about here
uh i need to get your information out
you know and we'll send we'll
we'll forward this to the technical
department i'm like what
what do you mean forward to the
technical apartment this is 24-hour
technical support
so why aren't you who are you what are
you doing like
what questions can they actually answer
so you call you you hit up this company
on the chat
and they don't know [ __ ] i'm like what
are you talking about right
so then i get and then i'm that kind of
guy i like i get into it with people
about these kinds of things like
and i know i shouldn't but sometimes i
just do like just side note i remember i
went to uh
gamestop i'm going to gamestop some
young kid is working there
i have bought like a used whatever it
was right
i bought a used device like a controller
or something from there i forgot what it
was but i just never forget this
interaction though
so i bought the used controller and i'm
bringing it back and i'm going here this
doesn't work
and then the kid behind the counter is
like yeah that's not well you know
that's not our responsibility because
the people that
sold it to us it was broken when they
sold it to us and so it's not our
responsibility
i was like are you crazy are you do you
hear yourself no no
you sold it to me it is your
responsibility to make sure and he just
wouldn't let it go
like this kid was like no you're you
know no i could tell he just didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking about right
manager comes over and i'm one of these
types that i got to be like no no no
we going to get this right this kid
needs to know what the hell is going on
and i'm mr analogy so i tell the kid i
go look if you
if this was a restaurant and you got
some meat from a butcher
the meat was spoiled and you served it
to your uh
customers that's on you
okay you can't come out from the kitchen
talking about ooh is that meat spoiled
well
we can't do anything about that that's
not our fault uh the butcher sold us
that so if you need the butcher's number
uh to go complain no not now you are
responsible for the merchandise
that you sell you know manager comes
over
and so i had this talk and i'm trying to
become cause that's the worst thing you
could possibly do listen when you add a
customer service and you have an
issue if you act up if you acting like
whatever
that's good you give them a reason to
bow out of this because it's like sir
you need to calm down
if you're like that then they got you
but if you come with them like
um yes uh your employee is mistaken
about how this works
uh let me explain what he just said and
let's figure out how we can make sure
he gets it right next time like if you
could be like that
that is more [ __ ] than anything
you could possibly do man
uh so anyways so cut to now i'm in this
situation all right
and you know this person's telling me
like well if there's anything that we
could do to make our
you know our support better we would
love any suggestions then you know thank
you for
hitting us up and i go yeah i write to
get a guy back i go
the technical support should be for
technical support
how about the person on the other end
you
know how to work the machines that
you're selling
that you're talking about it literally
says technical support
so you know sorry sir we you know we
i i we can't help you right now sir
uh but i have your email and i'm gonna
of course they didn't get back to me
you know and of course you know i still
don't know what the hell is going on so
next thing i do is
i go to amazon because now i'm thinking
i bought this from amazon so now i'm
thinking you know what
i gotta i gotta give this back you know
i'm thinking myself i gotta send it back
because
it's not what i want you right so i and
so amazon has an area
of technical support you know you could
go and it says
do you need support with this device
that you just bought they have a little
area for that so i click that and go oh
wow maybe they can help me
so i say like yes i'm having some
trouble with the usb interface i need
some help with this you know
then they go would you like to return
the device or would you like a refund
you know would you want to return and
get another one do you want a refund i
go what i want is technical support
[ __ ] says it again do you want
technical do you want to return it you
know i go fine
you give me my money back so then they
go
they go she they the person goes all
right here okay we're gonna
issue a refund and don't bother sending
the device back
what i mean in my mind i was like
real really so i basically got a free
mixer from amazon
and and my like but the problem is
this [ __ ] still don't work properly so
i'm still stuck in a situation where now
i got this mixer i didn't pay for
but like that i got for free but it's
not working the way i want it to work
like it's like so like but amazon is
such a big company they make so much
money
that it's like it's easy for them like
when you have some product
that's under 500 they just look at cost
assessment and just go you know what
here's a refund and then you know
to keep it and deal with it yourself and
leave us alone
and i'm like damn is that where we're at
like is that where we're at in society
like i
i can't get this [ __ ] to work the way i
want it to work
like that's all i wanted i just i still
want it to work
properly right but i just thought wow
how much money is amazon making
obviously a lot because the dude is the
richest man in the world right
but it's like damn so that's the crazy
situation that happened with my uh
what's going on with my technical
technical support
all right so i had this other other
thing that i wanted to talk about let me
go to the picture
so let me show you guys the picture
right now this this uh
so this girl she's beat up 17.
she looks like chili's in like baton
rouge
she work out of chili's in baton rouge
okay so let me just say that again
it's baton rouge and it's a chili's
okay she tells these two women
in the picture and i think others hey
she's just trying to enforce
no mask no service and they beat her ass
they beat up this 17 year old girl
because they didn't want to wear masks
or they were like you know you don't
tell us what to do i don't even know all
the story about what happened
i just know that that's the story that
they put out like damn
like this is where we're at i hate
wearing a mask
i'm gonna be i'm gonna tell you right
now it's uncomfortable i can't stand it
in the same way i don't like wearing
seat belts
sometimes the [ __ ] is uncomfortable you
know but you do it for health and safety
i mean like i i prefer for me i prefer
not even to go out sometimes because i
don't want to wear a mask
i just hate i hate breathing through the
mask it's just
it's the worst like when i go to the
market with rachel like she wants to
browse and i'm like could you get what
you want to get so we can get the hell
out of here
because i just don't want to be in there
that long so you're going out to d
first of all this is the thing that
really okay
here's the ignorant ass part about this
too
and and by the way i understand both
sides of this scenario
so you go to a restaurant right
when you walk up to the restaurant they
want you to have a mask
on but when you go sit down
at the table that you're sitting at you
could take your mask off
because you're gonna eat you're right
there eating so yes
devil's advocate i understand if you're
like
i'm about to take this mask off we walk
in like 15 feet
and i'm gonna and then my mask is gonna
come off anyway like what what
what is the what's going on here okay
you just go a little step further though
you think well if you have to walk
by people who are eating food maybe they
don't want your
funky breath or your why you talking
some spittle come out of your mouth and
fly into somebody's ribs
okay so yeah they want you to wear a
mask
but i get that it's like this is a lot
it's silly
you know but you have to understand so
for these people
the other side of it is like you about
to be able to take your mask off
what the [ __ ] does it matter just put
the mask on
walk over to the table of seven wherever
you guys are sitting then you take the
mask off and you're fine
did what is going on that you have to
beat this girl up
some kid i mean damn by the way
if you need to wear a mask anywhere it's
chili's
okay obviously it's chili's so
this ain't you know we're not at ruth
chris
you understand we're not at like the
best steakhouse in l.a we're just saying
ocean prime
we had chili's so when you go to chili's
you damn sure you want to wear a mask
because i don't know the people that go
to chile i don't know where people have
been or what people are doing
you know you're out in public now we
don't know what's going on especially
when there's food involved and
mouths are open and smack and it's like
yes let's make sure that we stay safe in
this environment even when we're trying
to like provide a service
and feel some normalcy of sitting down
and eating and
with your friends and family but damn i
don't know if i ever want to go to a
place where i feel like
some some nonsense like this can can go
down
you know i like this is like when you
play blackjack
you go to vegas and you're playing
blackjack i don't know if you guys play
blackjack
but like i don't go to the 10 blackjack
table
you know why because at the 10 blackjack
table
there'll be somebody at the table that
that
won't stay on the 16 when the deal is
showing that they have to hit
you know i
i don't go to the 10 table because the
you know and you know because
you know you're gonna see somebody
making a choice where you go
yo dude let's play the math as a table
you about to mess up the whole hand
you know you that you know that's a 12
you're supposed to stay
it's like a 15 you stay again a 50 on a
15 if the deal is showing uh you know
a third a three because chances are it's
gonna be a number that's gonna make the
dealer bust
i mean that's just a basic math so
blackjack people
they know that so i don't go to the 10
table because i've been at the table
where i've been like yo can you please
hit that
and they're like no and i'm like [ __ ]
i'll give you ten dollars
here's here's ten you won hit the [ __ ]
you know what i mean like so
i don't go to the ten dollar table i
like to go to the 25
the 50 table because you know the people
there they serious about what's
happening
because they got 50 on the line per hand
right that's how i feel about chili's
chili's is a ten dollar table so when
you go to the ten dollar table
you're gonna get people making ten
dollar decisions so
hey i think it was ridiculous that this
kind of stuff is happening
not just that this chili's but it's
happening all over the place where
people feel like their rights are being
infringed on like you don't tell me to
wear a mask
i get it wearing a mask is [ __ ] i
hate it
but there's a reason for it you know it
helps not spread this
[ __ ] virus you know it keeps other
people safe so i mean
why make such a big deal out of it you
know it's not it's not like we're asking
people to like
well you know it's like we have to make
everybody shave their [ __ ] head
you know like let's say it was like like
lice
spreading all over the country and we go
you gotta shave your head it's like look
okay we're not asking you to shave your
head we just say hey can you cover your
mouth we say this anyway even before the
virus came about it was like
please don't cough or sneeze you we we
just naturally cover our mouth
who's gonna be the [ __ ] that's
like nah that's you
hatch you don't tell me to cover my
mouth
you know we don't like this anyway if
you're in a movie theater and a
[ __ ] sneezes three rows away
you're kind of looking at this person
like
yo cover your [ __ ] mouth sneezy
you know so i don't know we really got
to work on this uh
this uh i mean it's just weird-ass
behavior
uh you know in the country right now
about
about this you know i don't know
what else is happening in the world
here's some other things that
uh rachel hit me too now this is weird
like
i don't know you don't you don't know
you need a tongue scraper
until you use a tongue scraper and then
you're like
what the [ __ ] is that that came off my
tongue now i use
i have like a tongue brush and i don't
use it enough we'll be honest you know
what i mean i don't know what y'all
y'all can judge me all you want
i know most y'all looking right now or
like a tongue scraper most of y'all
don't even you just brush your teeth
maybe you like you know
but like you need a tongue scraper so
this is what it looks like there's a
picture of it right there
a tongue scraper you see you hold it and
you just like scrape your tongue
and you'd be surprised how much
nastiness comes off that and it just
makes your mouth
fresher and you know you i don't know
this is one
it's like it's like one of those things
you need to just add to your to your
routine of brushing your teeth and
flossing and all that kind of stuff like
i hate flossing too the flossing is so
uh but i get so i don't like flossing
with dental floss
i like to use those hook things with the
string in the middle where you can just
like put it in between your teeth
you know you make a thing of it so
that's another thing rachel added to my
thing but i went to the dentist like we
had this bet like because she thought i
had i had like a bunch of cavities and i
was going to be in trouble
because you never floss but i went to
the dentist the dentist was like
uh you'll never get a caffeinated cavity
your teeth are perfect you're fine
so you know i strut it back in like yeah
girl what you what was you talking about
with my teeth
but still he said the most important
thing he said he the dentist was like
flossing is even more important than
brushing your teeth you know so all
right so i added that to the routine but
i just want to throw it out there to
people like if you don't have a tongue
scraper you should get one
and then because i tell you that first
time you do a tongue scraper
at the end of the day you're just you're
gonna be like
what what the hell was that
another in the plus column of rachel uh
helping me out in life right all right
guys
you know what time it is now cause i got
a lot of good ones today so
i'm gonna put those on uh get going with
it and this
once again real world advice from a
grown ass man
all right we're here so i got some good
ones
um i got some good ones this week
so uh you know let's just get right
right into it
um this one was
any advice for someone who's afraid to
take the leap and bet on themselves
well i mean this is a tough thing anyway
but you know this just goes
overall about like having goals you know
you set goals for yourself and then to
achieve those goals just work backwards
you know so if you write down like i
want to achieve such and such
i want to achieve this then you look at
that and go well how do you achieve that
well there's steps that you have to take
so that's the next step in writing down
your goals is writing down
how do i achieve those goals and that's
how you build confidence in who you are
and what you're doing
so like if i had to give you examples so
being a comedian is like
how do you be a comedian you know it's
like you have to write jokes you have to
go perform those jokes but you also have
to perform them all the time you have to
practice you have to get good at it you
have to learn your point of view
there's so many check check boxes that
you have to check off before you can say
oh man i'm a real comedian
so if you find yourself looking at the
list
and checking off all those things then
you're going to have confidence in your
ability
because you're going to put yourself out
there and you're going to try to achieve
these goals and you're going to take all
the steps to achieve those goals
so if you're afraid you know
if you're afraid of taking a chance it's
because it's so big and daunting to you
because you're saying like i want to do
this and then you're you're thinking
about like well i'm not
that yet so what am i going to do in the
meantime well that's the planning
that's the like take a breath take a
step and again
plan it out see what you have to do
check your finances make sure
everything's in gear be practical be
sensible you mean take a chance take a
risk but make sure you have everything
set up once you start having that stuff
you're going to start having confidence
in your choices and decisions
and then boom there you go you're going
to take a swing and take a chance
you know what you might fail but if you
do it right
even if you fail you've set yourself up
that you've at least
added something to your repertoire
you've added something to like who you
are as a person or
or even your your skill set to try to
achieve whatever this goal is so
take bet on yourself by improving
yourself by
you know you know you know what i mean
just think of it like sports
just think of sports man you know if i
said how do you if
you if you said yourself i want to play
in the nba well you already know like
it's like well you have to have a
certain level of talent in the first
place you have to have height you have
to have
athletic ability let's say you have all
that well what's the next step okay well
you have to practice every day you got
to work on your shots
you see these guys they take 10 000
shots at practice and they're like
shooting and shooting and shooting and
shooting and shooting until they get it
right so you can understand that like
once i shot if i shot a ball a
thousand times and then towards the end
of that thousand
it starts to really go in good i'm gonna
now have confidence in my ability so now
i go oh you know what i'm ready to take
that shot in the game
but i can't just go from like doing
nothing to like you know i'm sitting at
the
clipper game and all of a sudden doc
rivers is like griffin
not blake eric griffin uh row seven
you're getting in
i'll be like what i'm getting in the
game well i'm not ready you know so then
you're gonna feel afraid and you're
gonna i'm gonna be like
i'm not i'm not ready for this situation
but life doesn't work like that so
just work on it all right here we go
i'm 34 years old do you think it's too
late to go back to school
i had my first kid recently
well i mean again this is just like the
other question in a sense of like
you know you're already thinking of the
end result you're already thinking about
god do i have enough time to do this
am i good enough to do this you know
you're already doubting yourself
in a question like this it doesn't
matter how old you are
you can go to school at any time as long
as you have if hey
if you have the means if your bills are
taken care of and right now the way the
world is
you know it's gonna be a lot of
homeschooling anyway even from the most
prestigious colleges so
you i don't believe in the concept of
you don't have time to do stuff
i can't stand when people say that you
know you go hey can you hang out i don't
have time
there's no such thing you have time you
always
make time for the things that are
important to you
you find a way to make that thing happen
so with this it's never too late
even if you have a kid you know it's
like that's then you have to start
thinking about okay so what is my kid
gonna do
when i'm doing this so then you know
you're planning it out
you have to think about babysitting do
you have a family support system of
people that can help you take
take care of your kid while you're doing
this you have to make time to study in
the same way you have to make time to
work out
at the same time you make time to do
hobbies do you make time for dating you
make time to watch your favorite
television shows
you just have to prioritize that this is
important to you
and you can make it happen the fact that
you're 34 the fact that you have a kid
means nothing those are just
the excuses that we put in our way to
stop us from achieving our goals and
dreams
or at least making the effort to achieve
our goals and dreams so
put yourself out there and stop doubting
yourself and just plan it out
you gotta plan be smart be practical and
plan
and you can make it happen two kids with
wife
been together 13 years we aren't happy
stay together for the kids oh this one's
tough
i had a buddy of mine i know that his
parents
did that you know they as soon as they
were adults all once the all the kids
were adults
their parents got divorced so late
in their lives you know but then you
hear about the
issues that him and his siblings
have with their parents and each other
i i just don't i don't think it works
you know when people say they're gonna
stay together for the kids
it's like acting as if the kids don't
know something's wrong
like the kids you people act like
the kids are gonna you know not see like
you know y'all really never talk you all
seem to fight or you all seem to like
not
want to be in the same room i mean kids
are intuitive to these kinds of things
like that's a learned behavior so
they're going to learn oh they see
this is how people are supposed to love
each other so
if you want to do anything for the kids
heal your relationship with your wife
you know f you know try to rekindle that
magic that made you guys want to be
together and have two kids
sometimes life gets in the way you know
we let financial
pressure get in the way of our happiness
we let you know we don't follow our
dreams
sometimes it seems as if having kids
derails your fantasies dreams and hopes
also so then
you you know and then you guys blame
each other for that like you
got pregnant and we wanted to do this
and she's like you
got me pregnant and i never got to do so
y'all blaming each other
maybe it's time to like take a breath
and just be like
hey can we heal this relationship not
for the kids
for you for each other because
you want to really represent
a happy healthy home
so those kids can achieve that
themselves too
because trust me they know y'all don't
like each other
they can see it they can feel it
sometimes it's
tangible when two people can't stand
each other you just know
you can't pretend you know so
if you can't work it out i suggest you
work
get out of that you all need to like
have serious talk with the kids being
like look mommy and daddy don't love
each other anymore we love you and then
you make you make sure you make their
lives
the best it can possibly be in that
situation but don't fool yourself into
thinking
that these kids don't know what the hell
is going on
i mean this happens in a lot of
relationships you know we lose the the
fire the passion the love i mean that's
why you have to like
continuously you know work on
being better with each other you know or
take responsibility too like what is
going on with you
that you have this dislike
resentment find out why you feel that
way
find out what's going on what are you
what do you think you're lacking in your
life
that you're blaming it on your wife what
are you not doing
or what did you not what were you not
able to do because of having kids or
because if you're married like whatever
it is you're in your head about
figure that out and maybe figure it out
together
and then the next thing you know you
guys
start talking again you you rekindle
that fire that you once had
and then that's what you want to show
your kids that's the best thing for them
is to see their mother and father
you know in a
happy relationship or as close to it as
they
possibly can be but if you can't achieve
that
make sure you're showing them as much
love as you can
because kids aren't stupid man they're
not stupid
they know
all right here's one he says i just this
guy says
how do you how do i find a connection
with
women when when you don't know
what you're looking for well
that's exactly how you find the
connection because you sh
like i'm not a believer of having a
recipe you know like a huge recipe list
like yes if you're like someone like you
know there are certain like basic things
you might want to have like you want to
be the same height
you know whatever your things are that
you might have some do's and don'ts and
some unacceptable negatives on your list
but like you're not you don't
necessarily need to know what you're
looking for
that's the beauty of like connecting
with someone is like
exploring what you what you're looking
for exploring by like
sitting out and that's what dating is
supposed to be about we've turned dating
into swiping and it's just
instantly about gratification it's about
like you know
hooking up with this person or this
person's attractive and it all becomes
about
sex and and the conquest of that as
opposed to like
making a connection like you make a
connection by you know you go out on
dates
really talk to people get off the stupid
devices and actually talk on the phone
meet in person and you talk to this
person and you start to go
oh you know oh you you start talking
you bring up things politics religion
whatever you know even those
hot button topics you might find out
that you have something in common with
someone or you might even find out like
it's like hey
i don't like talking about this and that
person does and you go oh we don't have
the same interest and you move on
or you guys might you might find out
like
they have the same interest as you or
they're just interested in the things
that
they're interested in the fact that
you're interested in things
you could be in the comic book so you
know everything about them and you're
talking talking talking and a girl might
be like wow you're really a nerd and i
love that about this
you know you don't know what is gonna
make it click by sitting on your ass you
can't just have that recipe of like
looking through a
looking through a dossier you know you
can't have a file on every single person
before you meet them
were you looking oh you went to this
school you went to this you did that oh
you've
you like this you like that and go okay
it's not an eharmony equation
every single time so i say you just got
to get yourself out there
and talk to people
you know invest time in getting to know
yourself and be
open and vulnerable to letting people
get to know you and that's how you'll
connect
in my humble opinion this was close
to me because it says how does it feel
losing weight any advice for people who
are
struggling with their weight i mean i
think everybody
at some point is sort of struggling with
their weight right
um you know it is it's tough
i mean this is a big a thing that we all
deal with at all times
but you know you have to ask yourself
what are you what's really bugging you
you know
it's like when people say you know
they're they're struggling with their
weight i think it all boils down to we
all want to look good naked
we all want to be at our best self right
we just you know we think that there's
some like expectation of beauty that
we're like
i just want to look when i take my shirt
off i want people to
not be like you know i think that's how
we feel about it so you know what are we
really really struggling with is our own
self-image and how we feel about
ourselves
but yes i mean there is a certain thing
about being healthy you know being a fat
[ __ ] is not
healthy so like all these people who are
always like you know
feel good about you like no what are you
talking about this cholesterol there's
like there's a lot of things in l
that obesity is real man i've said this
a million times and i'll say it a
million times more
obesity is a killer it kills people all
the time it leads to a lot of problems
diseases inflammation it's all these
like inflammation leads to things like
dementia and that kind of stuff it's the
reason why i started working out because
i'm thinking about how what's going on
with my mom
who is not my mom's a very slender woman
so for me i was like damn i need to like
take care of my health and my age i want
to like be around 40 more years you know
so i don't care about this like hey feel
good about you don't let people no [ __ ]
you
you know you're you're doing people a
disservice you know it's always like the
more
left side too you know i just can't
stand that man
just this whole body positivity nonsense
man
obesity is a killer you know what
obesity is it's
liberals global warming they just deny
they deny that obesity is a real thing
and it should be stopped
it's just like global warming you know
what i mean 99
of scientists and doctors say hey
obesity is a killer this is a real thing
but you dumb [ __ ] want to be like oh no
feel good about you
like it's like no let's get it let's get
it let's get get it together so
when you it's about what you need to
focus on you need to focus on like so
eating healthier eating healthier
doesn't mean everything's a salad no
it's just eating healthier meaning like
portion control and and you know
exercising is not just good for losing
weight it's good for your brain
it's good for your health taking a walk
i mean all these things they talk about
is
this is what the doctor recommends and i
think that we as a society
should be should be pushing that more
than this whole [ __ ] body positivity
[ __ ]
so here we go i got a video this is how
i really want people to ask their
questions you just send
me your little video you can send it on
instagram to ask your question and then
i'll just copy and paste it and
you know we'll put it on here so here's
our guy i'm not sure what the guy's name
is i think
on his profile says chance gary so
that's who this is so let's hear what he
has to say
what's up eric so i've been seeing this
girl for like a month now
and now that i'm with her i have all
these other girls hitting me up on the
dms like wanting to go on dates and all
these like
wild texts and stuff like that and i'm
wondering like
how the hell am i going to stay like
satisfied when i constantly have these
new options coming
and like i know what it is to have no
options but now i have
multiple and i find myself like
continuously jumping jumping around so
i'm really want to just figure out how i
can like you know
take it easy and like appreciate one
without
wanting another so uh
[Laughter]
and we got little woo-woos there from
chance or gary or whatever the hell his
name is okay
so i get this trust me i actually can
relate to this situation
just because i was a guy i had no
options it was
i'm a late bloomer in life even when i
was younger i didn't have my first
girlfriend so i was in my mid-20s
okay so i totally get it you know you
feel like
you you know you feel like you deserve
like all of the
uh so now i got to get out here in a
dating pool and i got a date i got to
date around and date all these people
because you always feel like you missing
out but you know what
quality over quantity let me say it
again
quality over quantity
all right
take time that you're seeing a girl
give it your best give it your all hey
if you're seeing multiple women and you
haven't decided who
still be vulnerable and offer up your
best
until you figure out you know what this
is the one i want to spend
most of my time with because that's what
will end up happening
you know because sometimes it it you
expend so much energy
trying to stay away from this person
because you're like uh i'm getting too
close to that person so now you started
spending this energy to not spend time
with them just go with that
you're not letting yourself fully
invest in the person that's in front of
you
get the best out of that situation you
know and if it's multiple
even do it with that but you're going to
find that that's going to be hard
but you can't always be thinking about
what you don't have because then you're
going to look past
what you do have and always thinking
that you have other opportunities
you're not living the fullest
opportunity with the person that's in
front of you
you know being in us being in a great
relationship
it's hard work but it also could be one
of the most fulfilling things you've
ever done
and if you don't feel like that with the
person that you're with
it doesn't mean that you need to get out
of it but you have
you have to allow yourself the chance to
really
get to know this person really go
all in give it your your all the most
so you can see hey is this really it cuz
then
if you've done all that and it's just
not working
well then at least you could say well i
did my very best with this
but if you're constantly looking at
other things and looking at other people
like it's you know that's such a small
percentage
like if you think about it even even
like this sexual gratification that we
we constantly are looking for that we
think we're looking for when we're in
the dating
it's such a small part of the time you
ex
spend with a person it's an important
part it's a powerful part
it's a it's it's it's something that
like you know touches you
greatly you know but overall time
spent you're gonna spend more time
just shooting the [ __ ] than you are
having sex
you know you're gonna spend more time
you're just gonna spend more time doing
the other things
that are actually more important and
valuable to being a more well-rounded
person than that time you spend in bed
especially as you get to spend more time
with that person
you know it's like the most sex you have
is when you just getting to know
somebody you know you
like all that time you speak all the oh
this is great this is great this is
great
but like it's the true getting to know
it's the true
like do you have the same interest and
likes and and
and those things that you share though
those common interests
and you know those times that you spend
outside of the bedroom
those are the things that are going to
be long long-lasting so if you don't
give yourself the opportunity to
really delve in and explore those things
then what are you doing you're doing a
disservice to all those relationships
and don't be so damn insecure cause
that's really what it is you know
sometimes you always think like is this
the best i can do
and it's like it doesn't even work like
that
it's not about is this the best i can do
it should be
i'm gonna do my best with this situation
do your best it's not about we always
think like oh there's somebody better
out there for us
but what does that even mean when you
really think about it
you know there's always some nonsense
that people like you know there's so
many other like questions like this that
i got like you know
like just one guy sent us a certain
question i'm not even going to put it up
because it's you know so silly just
talking about like
you know you know i'm an ass man and
you know i'm real like i want my girl's
ass to be better so should i ask her to
do squats you know
and i'm thinking to myself you already
got with her
you already saw she had no ass you were
okay with it
and you started dating and now you're
getting bored or whatever and you're
finding things to find wrong with her
like oh yeah the ass ain't
exactly what i want then why the hell
did you get with her in the first place
you knew the job of dangerous when you
took it
so what are you doing it's just cause
those kinds of things that don't you
remember that all the things about her
that made you love her and like her and
want to be with her
those things you know they were so
beyond her ass but now you've forgotten
those things because you're not doing
that
stuff that that [ __ ] infatuation
feeling
once that starts to go away now you're
like well what am i left with well
that's
the stuff you got to work on so my man
here
give the people that you have in your
life
make sure you're giving them your best
you know for you because that's what's
going to be good for you
you know get out there do things explore
have great experiences
you know it's like why not take out one
of these girls that you and really take
her out take her on a fantastic date
a date that you enjoy too do something
you enjoy
and then you you'll have that memory at
least you'll be like man i went on this
great date one time even if it's like
that's
it but like just if you're with this
person
and you're looking at her thinking ah
man this she ain't just one that hit me
up on tinder
maybe i should no then you're missing
out on living in this moment
because you could still have this great
moment and then and then later just be
like it wasn't enough so i'm gonna move
on
and then you can have another great
moment but if you're always thinking
about what you don't have or what you
could have
you're not appreciating what's right in
front of you so i think you should start
doing that
appreciate what is right in front of you
all right y'all short and sweet today
well still long but
we don't always have to go an hour um
listen i really enjoy doing this yeah so
this is like
you know i'm just i'm rebranding my
podcast we're still riffing with griffin
but i want to riff with you guys
you know i just i'm i'm uh i feel like i
have some
some things to say you don't have to
agree with me but you know i'm going to
give you a thoughtful response and i
feel like this is a good approach a good
a good direction to go in and i
eventually want to keep it going further
i want to help you with your beefs
you know it's like if you have a
situation you guys
it's two of you or you know and you
can't get past something and you need
somebody
to help you like mediate well here i am
you know so
i'm still going to take questions i
would love them to be video questions if
not if you don't want to be on video you
just want to send them i'm going to do
the instagram
so make sure you follow me on instagram
eric griffin so make sure you follow me
because i'll every
at the end of every week i will put up
the post saying like okay now it's time
for questions
i try to answer some of them on
instagram too i put a little text and i
put it on my story
but i can't answer all of them i'm so
sorry but i'm going to try to answer
as many of them as i can and some of the
ones that really stick out to me are the
ones i want to put on the podcast like i
did today
so you know keep doing that and if you'd
like to say if you're comfortable enough
to send me video questions
please do that but you know once again i
really appreciate
you guys watching and listening to
riffram with griffin um
you know especially you guys that have
stuck through through the solo episodes
and you know
you've sent me a lot of great messages
saying like we love the solo episodes
we're with you
i really appreciate that because i just
get all in my head about everything
you know you know it's just like i just
want to know who my fans are
so and i want to make sure i'm servicing
them and then
the other people who become want to
become fans or
other people who are like well i'm
actually a fan of this other person that
i like when they're on your podcast but
other than that i don't want to watch
all right you know what fine so the ones
that want to be here all the time i just
want to make sure you guys are happy and
serviced and
again also remember that i game every
week every day i actually game
eric griffin gaming on twitch so make
sure you guys check that out
that's eric griffin gaming on twitch and
you know keep listening make sure you
subscribe
and you know i really appreciate you
know where
you guys we're coming up on 100 episodes
i can't even believe it
a hundred episodes that's more than a
year almost a year and a half's worth of
stuff
so it's pretty cool during these crazy
times i'm still putting out the content
and once again i appreciate you guys and
i'll see you next week